a lot of videos on getting bigger biceps
we'll say something like just do this
one or some exercise or this is the one
weird exercise you need to get massive
biceps that's not actually a case it's
much more about how you do rather than
what you do and so in this video I'm
going to talk to you a little bit about
how you actually get big around and the
principles behind it rather than just a
couple of different routes
so basically in order to get bigger arms
you need to work the biceps and the
triceps that's the first tip anything
that said you can get bigger arms by
just curling is a little bit misleading
because you will get bigger arms but not
as much because it could be if you're
also fixing equal amount on triceps a
lot of people notice already but just to
recap for those who don't already the
biceps are about one third of the arm
with the triceps making up the other
two-thirds that's what people say to me
it looks a bit more like 50/50 I think
even the pro bodybuilders probably will
spend at least the same amount of time
on the biceps as the triceps but the
point is don't neglect your triceps
whatever you do because if you're
neglecting triceps and you'll end up
with a little bump and you won't have
that nice underneath bit the mixer arms
actually look big so make sure you're
doing triceps and biceps at least 50/50
so that's one tip also by the way work
your deltoids particularly the lateral
deltoids and medial deltoid so that's
the head that goes along the side you
work it with moves like this raises
lateral raises the reason for this thing
is that it gives you a kind of like nice
triangle shape I'm still working on that
I don't have it quite there yet but if
you look at say Apollo Creed
what's that guy's name Carl Weathers
he's got the next awesome shoulders and
it makes his old arm look bigger so also
work on the arms so same in the app if
you want to have a cool-looking
midsection it's not just about getting
the transverse abdominus the rectus
abdominis also about getting the fleex
getting a flatter you know any one
muscle part any one muscle group is
actually normally a con combination of
multiple different muscles in order to
get that look of size and detail but
that's academic so let's go on to the
real meets this videos which is to say
that the real way to get bigger arms is
actually to train with lighter weights
and to do higher repetitions I've just
done an arm workout to get my arms nice
and pumped for you guys so this is
actually quite hard for me now but the
point is normally with these knees and
15 I would normally be able to do around
15 repetitions
20 of push and that's what you should be
aiming
to get site that's why all the big
bodybuilders say it's more about volume
than it is about weight trust me this
doesn't sit easy with me either because
I really enjoy really pulverizing myself
I can wait
notes that we're talking about
hypertrophy here we're talking about
muscle size and I'm Soni muscle strength
if it's getting bigger arms you're
interested in you want to accrete
increase the volume there's a
misconception that high repetition is
about toning and low repetition is about
building muscle that's pretty incorrect
doing low repetitions in a very high
weight creates more micro-tears
and that thickens the muscle fibers that
makes your arms much stronger that's why
actually the best way to build strength
is to do things like overcoming
isometric training where you're just
pulling and not getting anywhere it's
all about the force if you want to go to
strength if you want to go to size it
seems to be about getting to that point
where you're feeling the pump and the
best way of doing that is to push your
past self past failure and to do
high-volume that means high repetitions
and to do that the best way is actually
with a lighter weight so you aim for 12
15 or even 20 rep range that doesn't
mean you can't also deal with heavy
weight what I like to do is something
called mechanical drop sets I've talked
about them before on this channel the
idea is that you do few repetitions of a
very heavy weight maybe doing and under
underhand curls or overhand curls then
you switch to something like a a slight
cheat hammer curl and this allows them
to carry on doing high repetition after
you've already exhausted yourself with
that difficult wait you don't have to
change weight so you can go straight
into it as many as you can and as many
as this the point is you're keeping up
the momentum you're keeping up the high
repetitions you're kind of getting all
that blood all that oxygen into the
muscles fueling them with hormones and
with nutrients and fueling growth some
people talk about sarcoplasmic
hypertrophy versus myofibrillar
hypertrophy and this is the difference
between sarcoplasm being one that
creates size versus my apitla
being one that creates strength there's
all this talk about sarcoplasmic
hypertrophy things to do with stretching
the faster the faster being the kind of
tissue that surrounds the muscle
the joints and holds everything in place
they say you need to stretch that by
getting the pump by getting the oxygen
and blood in there in order to allow
yourself to grow more this is all very
weakly backed by science though there's
not that much explanation for why this
would be the case and sarcoplasmic
hypertrophy is in fact really just the
theory this is definitely not concrete
but from an experience if you look at
any big bodybuilder they'll use the kind
of Joe Weider
training principles to push himself past
failure and whether they're doing it
violate drop set and running the rap
whether they're doing some kind of
superset they will do high repetitions
and I've got some friends back at home
and they started using much lighter
weights and doing these crazy 20 rep
exercises really slow controlled
movements and they just exploded they
just ballooned I didn't believe it
either I've been doing it myself and my
arms have grown in size quite quickly so
as much as you might not like to hear it
if it's hypertrophy you're interested in
then you need to start training with
lighter weights and you need to do
higher volume shorten your rest period
and just get to that feeling where your
muscles feel like they're swelling
basically more pumped you can get them
in the workout the more that will
correlate with growth of course
everybody is different you might find
that this doesn't necessarily work the
same way for you as it has done for me
and my friends and all those
bodybuilders a lot of people say that
this is a way that you train more if
you're on steroids I'm not steroids
neither and my friends but I happen to
have quite good genetics you might find
it this type of training exhausts you
but give it a go anyways well that's all
I'm saying just give it a go try for a
couple of months doing rights awaits
higher volume and you should find you
grow even if this isn't the ideal wave
training for you if you've been doing
your training with higher weights with
and lower reps recently than just the
shock just the change to your routine
will make a big difference so hope
that's helped give it a go and hope to
see your arms getting huge thanks for
watching stay tuned for more videos like
this catch you later boy